so welcome to council of geeks my name
is Nathaniel a and I'm joined tonight by
Paul scoubidou and Ryan Daley and we are
going to kind of autopsying of a
post-mortem on Fantastic Four see what
can be possibly salvaged out of this
thing there we go has anyone in this
room seen the movie no we're hiding up
Fantastic Four why exactly yes that we
should we should in the interest of full
disclosure none of us have seen the
movie no none of us are planning to see
the movie mostly we're actually going to
be focusing on what happens now as
opposed to take e you know taking an
in-depth look at the movie itself box
office is in it was the major release of
the weekend it took second place with a
domestic total of just over 26 million
which for the record is about half of
what they were projecting I am getting
right now I am so happy to hear the box
office numbers I am happy to hear that
internationally you know because a movie
like transformers whatever the fourth
one was age of the station X danger yeah
that movie did the worst of any of the
Transformers movies domestically right
but it still may kill did billion
dollars in China so that franchise isn't
in danger right but overseas this
opening weekend Fantastic Four adjusted
marginally better than it did
domestically it's still only making
about 60 million dollars in total now
for perspective I think the last comic
book movie maybe the last movie based on
a Marvel property to do this bad was
with most riders spirits of vengeance
but from everything that has been
reported lately like Fox stalled out and
wouldn't let josh trank cast until the
last minute they they kept on holding
out and like a like signing contracts
with her cast now they eventually gave
him the cast that he wanted yeah these
were the actors that he wanted but they
waited until the last minute so he
couldn't prep that slowed down
everything supposedly they cut three
major set pieces from this movie days
before it was supposed to start shooting
and as another because people are
talking about for Fantastic Four
superhero action movie there's hard
any action in malia there are action
scenes from the trailers that are not in
this movie that was one of the major
things that from the reviews that I read
is that it's basically an hour buildup
yeah any other superhero movie you build
up with an action beat yeah you're
hearing it those are gone so it's just a
very slow build-up right to a climax
that nobody cares about from from
everything that I've heard we don't have
to put our our aging comic book angry
nerd hats on something to hold us apart
we don't have to pick on the fact that
it's different when the source material
on its face by every count it's just a
bad movie I talk to you actively I
talked to a friend of Facebook who's
never the coming didn't even know the
names of the fantastic four characters
mm-hmm and she said this was the worst
movie she seemed in two years oh I mean
here it is here is the the third film
coming up for this franchise that
doesn't it doesn't connect with fans
doesn't connect to critics doesn't
connect with anybody and it's a second
interpretation of this property right
right and so if they can't get it right
twice you know theoretically on these
two different wells I'm sorry time now
for technical but we're not gonna bring
up the Roger Sherman 90s thing which
ironically is that is this is still the
most true to the source material yes
that God that could be a whole separate
conversation I think Fantastic Four is
more difficult than some because the
spirit of those characters in the spirit
of the story is very very entrenched in
the 1960s and that particular realm of
science fiction but you know what so is
Star Trek anybody trying to make a
fantastic for movie is now fighting the
stigma of three theatrically released
mediocre to bad fantastic four movies in
addition to having to try and sell a
premise that is not current anymore now
if you want to make the comparison to
say Batman and Batman and Robin you know
Batman Begins had to overcome that sure
but it had at least that first Batman
movie that said look it was good once it
can we go to get that we've had three
strikes there because I heard a few
other people throwing out suggestions
for possible Corrections and one thing
that I had heard which I've heard before
is should that be a pure
at peace they tried it with x-men days
or not days of you 12 Days of Future
past George plot first class a cup
should they treat this as madmen with
the superhero genre could you I think
that would work but i think that is also
a conceit that it doesn't work in the
modern that's good I don't like making
that conception yeah somebody else
suggested that because of the weird
serial storytelling should Fantastic
Four be a television show would it have
a greater legs there than it does in
film my answer to that is it would need
Game of Thrones type of budget yeah you
I mean that that that's they just that
things might work unless you're willing
to go extremely far out into the realms
of space hyperspace inner space micros
memory all of these things you need it's
got any crazy babe I in scope I don't
see us getting a fantastic for movie
because let's remember Fox has no
merchandising rights for this right they
make money on the movie only right so if
the movie tanks since the movie loses
money they don't actually have a lot of
impetus to keep making you because I've
seen some people be like all you don't
they'll try again as a write scrap like
I don't it's not it's not worth their
money because at this point they're
there now losing money on this property
and it makes no sense for them to keep
the right so this kind of brings us to
what what happens now so what I see
happening from this is that Fox is going
to move fast they're going to I think
they're going to stop talking about this
movie pretty quickly I they already have
right and they're going to move directly
into our they're already on to I'm
Deadpool they're gonna start talking
about the x-men thing that's going to be
coming next and I think in the
background they're probably they're
gonna let it go so Fox it had already
greenlit and spooked and scheduled a
sequel the fantastic ports supposed to
come out in 2017 oh my gosh saturday
morning ok movie sort of opened up on
thursday nights and select screenings
but a message was friday on saturday
morning there were rumors coming out
that they're already swapping a deadpool
sequel for that same date in 2017 and
just forgetting
a fantastic four I don't think we're
going to get a sequel to this oh no the
one potential lifeline that this
property might have at Fox is if they
wanted to do an x-men Fantastic Four
crossover which a week ago I was saying
you know what they're going to blame
this movie's failure on josh trank and
let that be it but they're going to say
the characters itself are fine people
want to see these characters in a better
movie and the x-men the mutant franchise
can just be a shot of adrenaline to keep
this property's heart beating and we'll
just tie those together now mmm I look
at this I Simon Kinberg even said flat
out these are separate universes they
won't cross oh now they're thinking that
this is dead weight that could pull
x-men underwater its sequel is very
unlikely yes another reboot products
from Fox like what kind of timeline are
we talking about within three or five
years well I think they're taking clock
with marvelous seven because that's that
that was how long it took for the rights
to daredevil to revert I would say that
the odds of that are higher within that
time period we are going to get a lot of
comic book based movies because Warner
Brothers is finally getting in the game
and Warner Brothers is going to start
cranking out two or even three pictures
a year Marvel is going to be doing three
two or three pictures a year we keep
wondering if the the comic book movie
balloon is going to burst ant-man is the
only movie only comic book movie of the
three this summer that didn't
underperform based on what the studio
expected hmm age of Ultron technically
made a billion and a half dollars but it
underperformed based on what Disney was
expecting Fantastic Four facepalmed
face-planted i should say they mean if
if we start noticing a trend where these
movies become less popular and they're
also really crowded and star wars and
all of these other franchises start
picking up momentum Fox might just say
there isn't a market for this anymore
and even if they wanted to do a reboot
in 2020 it'll depend on how the new
spiderman does because the new
spider-man will have been the third
reboot in right a little bit over
decade yeah and if they're able to pull
that off then I they might they might
just say we'll just pretend this urban
third time's the charm right um okay I
mean I would say more likely than a
sequel you're still not particularly
likely I'm gonna break that down just to
the accountants and to the math because
you know somebody at a high level is
just going to look at the numbers of
this last thing and going and look we
spent 120 million which is I modestly
budgeted very modestly by the comic book
superhero movie and we still lost money
they could they could just let the right
slaps so I don't think that will happen
because even though I don't anticipate
Marvel would act on the property for a
long time I think if Fox decides that
they're not going to make another movie
with this property and I think they're
making that decision soon mm I don't
think they would just let it lapse after
six years I think they're like we can
sell this back Fox have been wanting to
do in x-men TV show for a long time mmm
and I would argue that there already has
been it was the first season of heroes
video um they really want to do that now
because it's a different media Marvel
needs to sign off on that because all
they have is film rights all right now
if Marvel make money from it don't do it
but this creates an interesting kind of
bartering situation where fantastic pork
could be used as leverage to grease the
skids for that so Fox could say we want
an x-men TV show will give you fantastic
for if you don't object let's just talk
about TV here's my question is what
currently successful science fiction
shows of the past decade can you think
of Battlestar Galactica Doctor Who or
some of that spin-off lead so these are
two very successful science fiction
property sedative that have young that
worked very very well and made a lot of
money now if we look at Battlestar
Galactica that's our galactic I've had
an enormous budget um the production
value is very high mom had a very loyal
finally it was critically acclaimed and
they pulled off some big stuff there
were starve you know there was Star Wars
level stuff
going on in the modern version of
Battlestar Galactica and if you look at
the effects that we're going on the CG
effects that they were doing it's pretty
complicated stuff right and so then I'm
going to slide over to dr. who right now
dr. who I'm using as a reference point
only because doctor who has that sense
of wonder and awe in it right the
effects are not very good the show is
Chino yeah the shuttle is honah Lee it
is in the right place and they are doing
a lot of stuff in Doctor Who where
they're telling stories about science
fiction stuff and science fiction sort
of ideas and theories without doing it
in these enormously expensive firefly
esque sort of but you know budget
spending now in that correct me if I'm
wrong about a-star galactic my memory of
that and in regards to budget yep is
that the outer space and cg stuff was
good it was of high caliber yeah but
happened very infrequently like there
would be two or three episodes stretches
of basically people on the interior sets
of that ship just talking so while yes
there was spectacle in it was high level
almost cinema ready spectacle they
didn't even have it every episode and
then in regards to Doctor Who part of
the reason doctor who gets away with the
effects not looking as good as other
standards are is it has a history of
that that was kind of the charm of
doctors are going back to the 60s so it
kind of gets a pass on that on that
basis I think an American audience which
is who this is going to be for sure does
not accept can't sure as a thing and
fantastic for specifically in regards to
their powers it's so intrinsic to what
they do and again it like we said we're
not superheroes they are explorers but
they're explorers their explorers who
can do incredible things and those
things are so fundamental to who they
are that if they're in situations where
they're not using those powers because
the budget doesn't allow them to do it
every episode you're going to be sitting
there going why the hell isn't he just
turning into fire the thing is though is
that I think in Fantastic Four is gonna
have a life right I think it is going to
be TV I think the property lends itself
to
that type of storytelling for one oh
yeah and I also think that somebody like
Netflix right Ken if they show up with
the other half of the budget but since
eight right which is on netflix right
now and i'm not saying these properties
are the same it's a very expensive show
right with very high production values
they're shooting in eight different
locations around the world right they're
spending a ton of money just got renewed
for a second season um and if someone
like netflix can show up to produce a
show of that kind of caliber i think
they can do the same thing with
something like fantastic forward without
having to go to HBO or Showtime then
this you sort of you talked me into
thinking about this a little bit
differently because in my dream scenario
we would get four or five fantastic four
movies in quick succession because there
are so many great stories that are so
different from each other like that
we're certain that they they lock
themselves in to dr doom because he's
the most famous blood sure there are so
many elements from the first 50 issues
of those comics that you can do that are
just larger than life and just fantastic
if we could get a more serialize if we
could get a TV version like a series
that had a real significant budget i
would love if they would do it I just
I'll make the comparison to darker
because I think if you're going to make
it a TV show it should have that same
targets you'd be like every member the
family can sit down and enjoy this but
the kinds of networks that are spending
the money that you would need you to
make the effects work don't cater to
that audience we might see a change with
Supergirl maybe they'll let's make a
bunch of really cool commercials 45
seconds high budget we need to
absolutely scrap origin not just because
people are sick of origin stories but I
think functionally the Fantastic Four
work best as an established mm-hmm thing
in the world not something that the
government is questioning and wondering
can we trust like they're here we trust
them these are the people we go to and I
think we need to jump ahead to that
point if you need to explain it you do
it somewhere an act to and it's a 10
minute flashback yeah I
I have nowhere else to put this talk but
I just kind of got to throw it out there
how do they keep screwing up dr. doom he
is a combination of the most classic
villain aspects ever he's a dictator
he's a mad scientist he has a suit of
armor and sometimes he does magic you
have to try to screw that up he's bookie
I think I could accommodate all the kind
of don't know but so are the Fantastic
Four combination of all of those things
scares them the fact that he's a master
of crazy robot science and magic that's
that's a tough sell vine drop the magic
but they keep dropping the fact that
he's a dictator and I think that he
looks like a robot and talks like
Dracula these are no I love the
character and I think there are ways of
doing him right you just you need to
exercise a little bit of patience and
you need to assume your audience is not
stupid and I think a lot of studios do
yeah because people see stupid movies
yes not this one no I didn't know
sometimes they skip stupid movies better
some reason they they're still gonna see
transformers so you know what what the
hell do we know you know what I mean
ultimately here's the thing and here's
kind of why I I wish Marvel had the
rights back I don't necessarily need to
see the Fantastic Four on screen I do
want doom and them in the MCU though and
I've said this before that the Marvel
movies are dark they're starting to
triple the over their feet on villains
in general and they're they're getting
very generic and I would love them to
have a everybody Riley round here's a
big standard villain who we can't we
can't just swoop in and take out i think
doom ruling Latveria with an iron fist
with diplomatic immunity who they can't
just go in and dismantle his government
would be awesome dr. conversation I
wasn't actually a part of who ant-man
but what am I thought so after coming
out of a man was that I and I think we
had agreed on this was that I didn't
ever need to see another ant-man movie
no I whoa I'll be very happy to see him
turn up in
war and anywhere else they want to use a
Benelli he doesn't need another solo
movie so um with that kind of thread and
I'm not saying you can't make a
fantastic for movie because I think you
can but maybe it's not and this is the
monster this argument necessary in order
for those characters to exist within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe how they could
show up in like I infinity war thing
they would actually be terrific
supporting characters in a later
spider-man movie I think they would fit
into infinity war really well both in
terms of the story and in terms of being
introduction point because if it's like
there are invaders coming from space we
need a science Spacey guy Michael I know
this guy here and here's Reed Richards
just shows up because they because they
called the the science Spacey guy that
they needed it wilts who you know who's
the smartest guy in Psych of the Marvel
Cinematic you know well then the Marvel
Universe right and even though I would
want them to be part of the shared
universe i mean dr. strange is going to
open up parallel dimensions and other
things yeah with the Infinity stones not
sure they could they could show up
coming out of the portal from my another
dimension and just say we're from well
not from your same world we're from a
different earth where we are the only
reason I I rather they did that's not
that that's that's the first step to
introducing the Marvel Zombies universe
so and let's not go there alright Robin
curtain is big on yeah hello walking
dead right now yeah and key 8 i'm sure
there's a junior executive was just a
stack of marvel zombies on his desk
anyway I feel like we kind of wound down
to a natural point there we didn't talk
about Josh Trank's semi-public
self-destruction and I you know what I
think it's probably a six of one half
dozen of the other in terms of didn't
tweet the night before the movie came
out basically distancing himself from
the movie yeah he just read it and then
delete it but it doesn't matter because
it's the internet it's out there wants
it's out there forever right that you
know
there was a much better version of this
movie that existed a year ago it's not
what's being released he's offering
ensuring meal he won't get hired by fox
again Alicia he was already fired from
an upcoming Star Wars movie so he's not
gonna work at Disney and well she the
thing is i think his career i will be
surprised if it ever recovers seriously
after this because he'll make games
movies but it's not gonna put no no
he'll never be granted this kind of
budget or it's gonna be a very long time
before he is but i think as long as she
doesn't overdose and die which I think
well I whose actual fault this is is
going to be very unclear for a long time
i think is probably going to be a decade
or my people people who were involved in
the studio end of this need to no longer
be at that studio before we're going to
get a much clearer picture of what the
heck actually happened there's a
filmmaker named Jon Schnepp who just
released a documentary called the death
of superman limps what happened which
was bitching it's it's all about what
was going to be Tim Burton's civilian
lives movie with snake exchange and it's
all about how it like it's a very in
depth from what I've heard and i'm going
to download at some point i've heard
it's a great movie and it really he
talks to everybody yeah who isn't but
the reason everyone was willing to talk
is because it was 15 years ago right
exactly so i think i'm decade from now
we're going to get a great documentary
about what happened to this fantastic
four movie and that that i will actually
go to the theater will wrap it up there
so I know you guys have your projects
you want to plug Paul what you got going
on so i'm working on a comic for rising
sun comics called armadillo justice it's
about a bunch of armadillos from space
that finance it's pretty much awesome um
not to mention red and green thumb that
Ryan and I are the writers of which you
know is out there and funny I don't know
like I was just really other day I was
like haha that's not it yeah really the
kind of master that we get the dance so
that sounds about right m ryan i'm the
host of a number of podcasts that you
can find dead Bothan spies a star wars
podcast flowers and fishnets a black
canary podcast in the secret origins
podcast all of which are available for
download on
itunes check those out all right and one
other note for folks who are watching
the video we're doing something slightly
different because whenever we shoot
these we end up with anywhere from 45
minutes to about an hour and a half
where the stuff that I then cut down to
10 10 minutes 10 to 20 minutes but the
point being the video is always very
truncated so kind of as an initial
experiment we'll see if we stick with it
i'm actually going to release this
entire conversation pretty much unedited
as a podcast it will be the Council of
geeks podcast which will hopefully be
available on iTunes it will definitely
be linked there is a blogspot council
geeks blogspot com I meant also the
facebook page Council of geeks I will
link to that when it's available so if
you're interested in even more than what
you got to see it wouldn't be yeah and
why wouldn't you be you can check that
out and I'll include a link in the
description of this video and so thank
you guys very much for joining me and
until next time this council is
adjourned you're gonna cut out the
racist part where we talked earlier
that's that's not gonna go on the final
per night oh yeah of course I yes I I I
always that ranch was dark what's wrong
with you listen